it is election season and there is a
runoff between candidate a versus
candidate B and we are pollsters and
we're interested in figuring out well
what's the likelihood that candidate a
wins this election well ideally we would
go to the entire population of likely
voters right over here let's say there's
a hundred thousand likely voters and we
would ask every one of them who do you
support and from that we would be able
to get the population proportion which
would be this is the proportion that
support support candidate a but it might
not be realistic in fact it definitely
will not be realistic to ask while all
100,000 people so instead we do the
thing that we tend to do in statistics
is is that we sample this population and
we calculate a statistic from that
sample in order to estimate this
parameter so let's say we take a sample
right over here so this sample size
let's say n equals 100 and we calculate
the sample proportion that support
Canada Day so out of the hundred let's
say that 54
say that they're going to support Canada
Day so the sample proportion here is
zero point five four and just to
appreciate that we're not always going
to get zero point five four there could
have been a situation where we sampled a
different hundred and we would have
maybe gotten a different sample
proportion maybe in that one we got zero
point five eight and we already have the
tools in statistics to think about this
the distribution of the possible sample
proportions we could get we've talked
about it when we thought about sampling
distributions so you could have the
sampling distribution of the sample
proportions of the sample proportions
for portions and it's going to this
distribution is going to be specific to
what our sample size is for n is equal
to 100 and so we can describe the
possible sample proportions we could get
and there likelihoods with this sampling
distribution so let me do that so it
will
look something like this because our
sample size is so much smaller than the
population it's way less than 10% we can
assume that each person we're asking
that it's approximately independent also
if we make the assumption that the true
proportion isn't too close to zero or
not too close to one then we can say
that well look the sampling distribution
is roughly going to be normal so have a
normal this kind of bell curve shape and
we know a lot about the sampling
distribution of the sample proportions
we know already for example if this is
foreign to I encourage you to watch the
videos on this on Khan Academy that the
mean of this sampling distribution is
going to be the actual population
proportion and we also know what the
standard deviation of this is going to
be so let me decimate me that's one
standard deviation this is two standard
deviations that's three standard
deviations above the mean that's one
standard deviation two standard
deviations three standard deviations
below the mean so this distance let me
just in a different color this standard
deviation right over here which we
denote as the standard deviation of the
sample proportions for this sampling
distribution this is we've already seen
the formula there it's the square root
of P times 1 minus P where P is once
again our population proportion divided
by our sample size that's why it's
specific for N equals 100 year and so in
this first scenario let's just focus on
this one right over here when we took a
sample size of N equals 100 and we got
the sample proportion of 0.5 4 we could
have gotten all sorts of outcomes here
maybe 0.5 4 is right over here
maybe 0.5 4 is right over here and the
reason why I have this uncertainty is we
actually don't know what the real
population parameter is what the real
population proportion is but let me ask
you maybe a slightly easier question
what is what is the probability
probability that
our sample proportion of 0.54 is within
is within two times two standard
deviations of P pause the video and
think about that well that's just saying
look if I'm gonna take a sample and
calculate the sample proportion right
over here what's the probability that
I'm within two standard deviations of
the mean well that's essentially going
to be this area right over here and we
know from studying normal curves that
approximately 95% of the areas within
two standard deviations so this is
approximately 95% 95% of the time that I
take a sample size of 100 and I
calculate this sample proportion 95% of
the time I'm going to be within two
standard deviations but if you take this
statement you can actually construct
another statement that starts to feel a
little bit more I guess we could say
inferential we could say there there is
a 95% probability that the population
proportion P is within within two
standard deviations two standard
deviations of P hat which is equal to
zero point five four pause this video
appreciate that these two are equivalent
statements if there's a 95% chance that
our sample proportion is within two
standard deviations of the true
proportion well that's equivalent to
saying that there's a 95% chance that
our true proportion is within two
standard deviations of our sample
proportion and this is really really
interesting because if we were to able
to figure out what this value is well
then we would be able to create what you
could call a confidence interval now you
immediately might be seeing a problem
here in order to calculate this our
standard deviation of this distribution
we have to know our population parameter
so pause this video and think about what
we would do instead if we don't know
what P
if we don't know our population
proportion do we have something that we
could use as an estimate for our
population proportion well yes we
calculated P hat already we calculated
our sample proportion and so a new
statistic that we could define is the
standard error the standard error of our
sample proportions and we can define
that as being equal to since we don't
know the population proportion we're
going to use a sample proportion P hat
times 1 minus P hat all of that over and
in this case of course n is 100 we do
know that and it actually turns out I'm
not going to prove it in this video that
this actually is an unbiased estimator
for this right over here so this is
going to be equal to 0.5 4 times 1 minus
0.5 4 so that's 0.46 all of that over
100 so we have the square root of 0.5 4
times 0.4 6 divided by 100 close my
parentheses enter so if we round to the
nearest hundredth it's going to be
actual even we round to the nearest
thousandth it's going to be
approximately 5 hundredths so this is
going to be this is approximately 0.05
so another way to say all of these
things is instead we don't know exactly
this but now we have an estimate for it
so we can now say with 95% confidence
and that will often be known as our
confidence level right over here
with 95% confidence between between and
so we'd want to go to standard errors
below our sample proportion that we just
happen to calculate so that would be 0.5
4 minus 2 times 5 hundreds so that would
be 0.5 4 minus 10 hundredths which would
be zero point 4 4 and we'd also want to
go to standard errors above the sample
proportion so that would be that plus 10
and 0.64 of voters of voters support
support a and so this interval that we
have right over here from zero point
four four to zero point six four this
will be known as our confidence interval
confidence interval and this will change
not just in the starting point and the
end point but it will change the actual
length of our confidence interval will
change depending on what sample
proportion we happen to pick for that
sample of 100 a related idea to the
confidence interval is this notion of
margin of error margin of error and for
this particular case for this particular
sample our margin of error because we
care about 95% confidence so that would
be two standard errors so our margin of
error here is two times our standard
error which is B zero point one or zero
point one zero and so we're going one
margin of error above our sample
proportion right over here and one
margin of error below our sample
proportion right over here to define our
confidence interval and as I mentioned
this margin of error is not going to be
fixed every time we take a sample
depending on what our sample proportion
is it's not it's going to affect our
margin of error because that has
calculated essentially with the standard
error another interpretation of this is
that the method that we use to get this
interval right over here the method that
we used to get this conference to get
this confidence interval when we use it
over and over it will produce intervals
and the intervals won't always be the
same it's going to be dependent on our
sample proportion but it will produce
intervals which include the true
proportion which we might not know and
often don't know it'll include the true
proportion ninety-five percent of the
time I'll cover that intuition more in
future videos we'll see how the interval
changes how the margin of error changes
but when you do this calculation over
and over and over again ninety-five
percent of the time
your true proportion is going to be
contained in whatever interval you
happen to calculate that time now
another interesting question is is well
what if you wanted to tighten up the
intervals on average how would you do
that well if you wanted to lower your
margin of error the best way to lower
the margin of error is if you increase
this denominator right over here and
increasing that denominator means
increasing the sample size and so one
thing that you will often see when
people are talking about election
courage coverage is well we need a
sample more people in order to get a
lower margin of error but I'll leave you
there and I'll see you in future videos